[Music]
good morning John it's Friday May 11th
for our birthdays mom and dad got us new
bikes it's got thorns birthday next week
so she got one too and now we have two
really nice bikes so we can ride around
town all the time we can ride her back
to the garden and we won't have to use
any fossil fuels or create any carbon
they're really nice - thanks mom and dad
and happy Mother's Day mom do you know
what I love my mom but also I love
questions about superheroes who would
win in a fight between Batman and
Superman
I won't that one's not very interesting
but there are lots of superhero
questions that I'd like to answer I
especially like to think about what kind
of superpowers I would like to have if I
could have superpowers I mean you can't
really beat Superman for having
superpowers unless you could travel in
time though that could definitely get
very confusing very quickly I think that
that would be probably the hardest
superpower to have as you get more power
dealing with that power becomes more
difficult all superheroes deal with that
I think a time stopping man would have
even more problems where do you draw the
line I mean you could save everybody as
long as you didn't age while you were
saving people
you could save everybody in the world
pretty much and if you did age then
you'd have to use your time very wisely
you'd have to save the maximum yeah that
would be a hard power to have but it
would be the most power I think of any
superhero unless you were Superman and
you could travel in time that would be
more power and you'd also have to make
sure that you didn't accidentally negate
your own existence while you were in the
past I would probably not mess with the
past if I was a time-traveling superhero
you go back and you try and stop the
Holocaust and suddenly you've
disappeared put a needle and hitler's
eye when he's a baby but it'd be okay to
kill baby Hitler I mean it's just a baby
this is why it would be so hard to be a
time-traveling superhero I don't know
I'm interested in people's opinions on
whether it would be okay to kill baby
Hitler now the reason I'm talking about
this John
because one of the common ters asked me
what I would do if I woke up in the
morning and had spider-man's powers I
mean I gotta be honest I definitely
start out the way that Peter Parker did
in spider-man 1 by taking off my shirt
and flexing in the mirror and then I
would probably get Kathryn and flex it
her and then I might go downtown and
flex it random people I've never really
had flexible flexible flex ish flexing
the capability of flexing really and I
think that I would enjoy that beyond
that I would probably move away from
Missoula because spider-man's powers in
Missoula Montana would be fairly useless
swing from the seven storey building to
the six storey building and then I could
swing back over and over again
I think spider-man in Missoula would be
very bored I think you would go hiking a
lot I think actually that the
awesomeness of the superhero is
dependent on the size of his city
because if there's not a lot of people
to save what do you need a superhero for
the superhero in Missoula would be very
part-time like you work at the taco shop
and then be like guys I gotta go I just
been listening in on the police scanner
and there's been an accident on highway
22 and I have to travel back in time and
use my Superman powers to stop it
so yeah if I was spider-man I would
either keep it a secret and just flex a
lot or I would move to a big city and
actually get something accomplished Wow
I sure did spend an entire video talking
about superheroes hah nerdfighters see
you on Monday